"THE FIVE"
"THE FIVE."
>> Greg: AT A RALLY LAST NIGHT,
THE
PRESIDENT SLAMMED THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S ATTORNEY WHO
HAD BEEN BOWING TO GET RID OF
TRUMP AS FAR BACK AS 2017.
IT HAPPENED AS HE'S COMING OFF
THE PLANE.
>> President Trump: COMING OFF
THE PLANE AND THEY HAND ME, LOOK
AT THIS CHARACTER.
OKAY.
THEY JUST HANDED ME THE STORY.
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S ATTORNEY SAID
IN 2017.
YOU KNOW WHEN THAT WAS?
THAT WAS A LONG TIME AGO.
THEY SAY JANUARY 2017.
THE IMPEACHMENT WILL FOLLOW.
IT'S ALL A HOAX.
IT'S A SCAM.
>> Greg: A COUP, IT'S TRUE.
HE HAS LONG CALLED FOR TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT.
HE HAD ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH
THE DEMS.
ALL YOU NEED IS AN AMBITIOUS
LAWYER AND AN EMBEDDED ACTIVIST
WILLING TO BLOW A WHISTLE ONLY
DEMOCRATIC DOGS CAN HEAR.
HERE IS A WHAT IS, ACTUAL TWEETS
PROVING INTENT TO OVERTHROW A
PRESIDENT.
ONCE AGAIN, WE SEE HOW THE MEDIA
AND THE DEM'S DESIRES COINCIDE
PERFECTLY.
WAY BACK THEN, THEY ALSO TWEETED
THIS.
"I PREDICT CNN WILL PLAY A KEY
ROLE IN DONALD TRUMP NOT
FINISHING OUT HIS FULL TERM AS
PRESIDENT."
HOLY.
MAYBE HE WAS JUST APPLYING FOR A
JOB AT CNN, OR PERHAPS HE WAS
WORKING WITH THEM ALREADY.
THE DEMS, "THE TIMES," THEY ARE
ALL WORKING FOR EACH OTHER
TRYING TO MANIPULATE YOU WITH
THE SAME OLD STORY AND ALL THE
OTHER NONBOMBSHELLS.
I MEAN, DON'T YOU FIND IT REALLY
ODD HOW THE NETWORKS BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO PROTECT THIS
SPECIAL WHISTLE-BLOWER BECAUSE
WELL, THEY HATE TRUMP.
THEY FIND THE WHISTLE-BLOWER FOR
BEARING COVERAGE OF A KNOWN
MOLESTER.
I GUESS COVERAGE TAKES PRIORITY
OVER.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE TWEETS THAT
THEY DID BACK TWO YEARS AGO.
WHO HASN'T STARTED.
TOMORROW WILL TAKE THEIR PLACE.
REBELLION, IMPEACHMENT WILL
FOLLOW.
SO, JESSE, YOU WERE NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE SAYING THE WORD, COUP.
NOW YOU CAN SAY ALL YOU WANT.
>> Jesse: IT'S OKAY NOW.
THERE'S A COUP DOUBLE STANDARD,
RIGHTS, JUAN?
THIS IS ALSO WHY I DON'T TWEETS.
IT'S GOING TO COME BACK TO BITE
YOU.
WHY GIVE YOUR OPPOSITION MORE
AMMUNITION?
THEY ARE GOING TO DO IT ANYWAY.
THEY WOULD BE LEFT OUT OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.
NOW THE LAWYERS COMPROMISE.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S COMPROMISE.
SCHIFF COMPROMISES.
THE WHOLE THING IS CROOKED,
OKAY?
THEY WANTED TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP THREE YEARS BEFORE
THE PERFECT PHONE CALL.
HE HADN'T EVEN MADE THE PERFECT
PHONE CALL AND THEY WANTED TO
LAUNCH A KILL.
THAT'S HOW SICK IT IS.
NOW, THE CONSERVATIVE ONLINE
MEDIA HAD TO GO BACK AND FIND
THESE TWEETS.
THIS IS A MONTH AND A HALF AFTER
THIS WHOLE THING STARTED.
WHY HAVEN'T THE NETWORKS FOUND
ANYTHING ABOUT THE ATTORNEY FOR
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER QUESTION
MARKETS BECAUSE THEY'RE WORKING
WITH HIM AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
KNOW WHO IS RUNNING THE COUP,
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT THE
PUBLIC TO KNOW WHO IS RUNNING
THE COUP, BECAUSE THE LEFT IS
RUNNING THE COUP.
IF YOU LOOK AT RUDY, THE LAWYER
FOR THE PRESIDENT, THEY KNOW
EVERYTHING ABOUT RUDY.
THEY KNOW WHAT HE EATS FOR
BREAKFAST.
HE CAN'T GO ANYWHERE WITHOUT
THEM.
MARG SAYED IS TALKING ABOUT
LAUNCHING A COUP BEFORE THIS
WHOLE THING HAPPEN.
THEY TRIED TO KEEP IT IN THE
DARK FOR THREE YEARS.
ALSO, GREAT POINT IN THE
MONOLOGUE ABOUT A WHISTLE-BLOWER
DOUBLE STANDARD.
THEY WANT TO GO AFTER THE
PRESIDENT, BUT THEY DON'T WANT
TO GO AFTER AN INTERNATIONAL
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING RING,
BECAUSE IT HAS.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S.
WE ALL KNOW WHO IT IS.
GOOGLED THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
YOU CAN FIND IT.
IT'S OUT THERE.
FOX PROBABLY HASN'T 99% TO NAIL
DOWN WHO IT IS.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE FIRST.
EVERY OTHER NETWORK DOESN'T WANT
TO DO IT BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
PROTECT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
BECAUSE IT'S A PART OF THE
SCHEMA, BUT IT IS NOT ILLEGAL TO
OUT A WHISTLE-BLOWER THROUGH THE
MEDIA.
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO REPORT
IT.
>> THERE IS AN OBLIGATION TO
REPORT A WHISTLE-BLOWER FROM
RETALIATION.
IT IS NOT ODD THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO PROTECT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING TODAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LOOK FAR INTO
THOSE TWEETS TO REALLY QUESTION
AS AN AMERICAN THE LAWYER FOR
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT A COUP,
BUT SAYING "WE WILL GET RID OF
HIM."
TALKING ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
IN ANOTHER TWEETS, LISTING
JOHNSON, IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
HE SAID THIS IN MAY.
THIS IS A LAWYER PROTECTING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I SPOKE TO FORMER U.S. ATTORNEY
GUY LEWIS THIS MORNING.
HE SAID THAT IF YOU ARE A LAWYER
ON THE OTHER SIDE, I HAVE GREAT
CONCERNS ABOUT THESE TEXTS AND
SO SHOULD ALL OF YOU.
WHY NOT QUESTION IT, JUAN?
ARE YOU WILLING TO QUESTION THE
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING THIS
WHISTLE-BLOWER?
>> Juan: PEOPLE HOLDING UP
SIGNS SAYING "IMPEACH DONALD" --
I DON'T GET IT.
TO ME, THIS IS MORE OF AN EFFORT
TO DISTRACT, DISTRACT FROM EVEN
MORE TESTIMONY, DISTRACT FROM
THE TUESDAY ELECTIONS AND
REPUBLICANS GETTING --
OKAY.
THE REALITY IS THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THING IS NOT
RELEVANT, BECAUSE WHAT YOU SAID
IS TRUE.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS PROTECTED
AGAINST RETALIATION BY LAW.
THE LAWYERS ARE NOT RELEVANT.
HE IS REPRESENTED REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS.
NOT RELEVANT.
YOU ALWAYS INTERRUPT.
LOOK, I DON'T INTERRUPT YOU.
IT DON'T INTERRUPT ME, ALL
RIGHT?
WHAT IS RELEVANT IS THAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S ACCOUNT HAS
BEEN AFFIRMED, FIRST BY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE OFFICE.
SECONDLY, IT'S BEEN CONFIRMED BY
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
CALL, PEOPLE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S BEEN CONFIRMED BY
DIPLOMATS.
THE EVIDENCE KEEPS PILING UP.
READ THE TRANSCRIPT, SAYS
DONALD TRUMP.
READ THE TRANSCRIPT.
WHAT DO YOU GET WHEN YOU READ
THE TRANSCRIPT?
THERE'S A SHAKEDOWN.
SONDRA, THAT'S WHAT'S RELEVANT.
>> WELL, I THINK THAT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A COUP AND
REMOVING THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO WAS VOTED FOR
IN A DEMOCRACY, IT ACTUALLY DOES
MATTER WHAT THE INTENTIONS ARE
OF THE ATTORNEY.
NOW, THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THE
ATTORNEYS REACHED OUT TO SOMEONE
TO BECOME THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
ONCE THEY SAW SOMETHING THAT
THEY THOUGHT ROSE TO THE
OCCASION OR IF THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WENT TO THEM
FIRST WITH SECONDHAND KNOWLEDGE
OF THIS PHONE CALL.
IT WASN'T JUST THE TWEETS ABOUT
THE COUP, BY THE WAY.
HE ALSO HAS TWEETS ABOUT
PRAISING THE ATTORNEY.
IT'S AMAZING THEY WERE DOING THE
WORK.
HE ACTUALLY WANTED TO REACH OUT
AND HELP HIM.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT INTENT
AND CREDIBILITY, THE OTHER
ATTORNEY FOR THE SAME
WHISTLE-BLOWER HERE.
HIS NAME IS ANDREW.
HE ALSO TALKED ABOUT REMOVING
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE THROUGH
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
WE
WHERE HAVE WE SEEN THAT?
IN THE NEW BOOK THAT IS
REPORTEDLY COMING OUT.
>> Sandra: THE LAWYER
RESPONDED BY LAUGHING AT THE
CRITICISM.
THOSE TWEETS WERE REFLECTIVE
OF --
>> Juan: LET ME JUST SAY, IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GO AFTER PEOPLE,
GO AFTER RUDY GIULIANI WHO IS IN
DEEP TROUBLE FOR HANGING OUT
WITH PEOPLE WHO ALLEGEDLY COMMIT
CRIMES.
>> Greg: THIS IS A REALLY DUMB
QUESTION.
IF A PERSON PUBLICLY ANNOUNCES
BEFORE ANY INFRACTION OR CRIME
COMMITTED, THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO GET YOU.
LET'S SAY A PROSECUTOR SAID,
JESSE, I DON'T LIKE WATERS.
I'M GOING TO BUST YOU.
THAT PERSON CANNOT, HE SHOULD BE
RECUSED FROM ANY CASE.